démarrage opération interview
décontracté c'est bon oui on
[Musique]
démarre nos origines bien tout a
commencé par un
puis un C bonjour et ensite une vie de
mission secrète nousion la mor je
recommand de faire de suite att BL desux
il on p pres pas de blen et regard tout
à fait àe d'habitude nous travillons
dans om seul enfin presque toujours seul
et un jour on est tombé sur des petits
nouveaux le vent du nord il s'appelle on
opérait plus ou moins de la même façon
il n'y a qu'une solution pour vous
mettre d'accord le travail d'équipe oui
voilà le travail d'équipe pourquoi
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous avez montré
ça à tout le monde vous avez fait la
connaissance de Kowalski maintenant
venez découvrir comment quatre pingouins
pas comme les autres sont devenus les
Pingouins de Madagascar bientôt
oui
ce qu'on faisait avant de devenir les
Pingouins de Madagascar il des spécial
on était trop doux et tropon c'est vous
ma
famille tu n'as pas de famille et on va
tous mourir quoi bah quoi je croyais que
c'était là-dessus qu'on s'était tous mis
d'accord depuis qu'on a quitté
l'Antarctique on a été dans le monde
entier voir toutes sortes de choses
incroyables Venise l'Allemagne un
quartier général super secret un repère
de méchant on a dû apprendre à se fondre
dans le paysage e vous avez vu c'était
moi à côté de Ricot on est passé maîre
dans l'art du
déguisement vous habitez chez vous Haran
vous avez fait la connaissance de soldat
maintenant venez découvrir comment
quatre pingouins pas comme les autres
sont devenus les Pingouins de Madagascar
bientôt attention les yeux vous allez
être tellement emballé parce que vous
allez voir que vous risquez
d'exploser je vous aurais prévenu
notre vie a commencé en Antarctique une
terre inhospitalière et glacée infesté
d'ennemis des f léopard les vipères de
la nature c'est pas les vipères les
vipères de la nature comment veux-tu que
je le sache j'habite dans cette fich en
partant de là on a fait le tour du monde
nous emporterons ça dans nos tombes
[Musique]
entendu et puis on est devenu une unité
d'élite connu sous le nom de pingouin de
Madagascar toi je te tiens disnous tout
chef c'est un bébé
pieuvre
désolé donc je savais pas que c'était
une interview je croyais que vous alliez
juste poser les questions ça va au feu
vous avez fait la connaissance de
commandant maintenant venez découvrir
comment qu pingouins pas comme les
autres sont devenus les Pingouins de
Madagascar le 17 décembre au cinéma
qui je suis je regrette mais cette
information est
confidentielle ce que je peux rééler
c'est que je suis le patron du V du Nord
Jere expion je marche
non quiè anim danger mort les men qui
comment ça vous voulez parler des
pingouin pas vous
fait est
sec commando d'élite secret d'élite
secret interespèce dont la vocation est
d'assister des animaux qui ne peuvent
pas s'assister tout
[Applaudissements]
seul le vent du nord contrôle toujours
la situation parce que personne ne lâche
un vent vous l'avez vraiment trouvé
géniale cette phrase vous l'avez mise
sur vos cartes de visite et tout le
reste vous avez fait la connaissance de
confidentiel maintenant venez découvrir
comment quatre pingouins pas comme les
autres sont devenus les Pingouins de
Madagascar
bientôt alors RIC on dit que vous êtes
plutôt du genre costaud
silencieux d'accord on va
continuer bien par quoi allonsnous
[Musique]
commencerarveil une pièce de
théâtre commence
[Applaudissements]
par mais il va dire quelque chose à un
moment vous avez fait la connaissance de
Ric maintenant venez découvrir comment
quatre pingouins pas comme les autres
sont devenus les Pingouins de Madagascar
bientôt